so I want to thank you for being here
today
privacy is maybe not the most popular
topic for all audiences so I really want
to thank you for being here and taking
some time with me today
this is my first time back in the States
for several years and I just got to say
a few things have changed since I was
last year but some things have remained
the same and it's really nice to be here
and to be talking with folks about a
variety of issues that we face today a
little more than four years ago the
streets of st. Louis and Ferguson
erupted in protest this was after the
killing of Michael Brown an unarmed
black teenager by the police and
regardless of your political affiliation
regardless if you looked at these
protesters as angry or brave as
justified or simply unsatisfied
regardless of your interpretation of the
protests in the street black Americans
and their allies of all races and
ethnicities and backgrounds took to the
streets to protest unfair treatment by
the police towards citizens of the
United States and this sparked perhaps a
conversation that maybe was ongoing in
many communities for a long time but
maybe as a nation we hadn't had as
United States nation maybe we hadn't had
in a while and as an international
audience perhaps we hadn't had in a
while and it's no secret that the
foundation of the United States is based
off of several values that today we
would classify as racist sexist and
oppressive this has been well documented
within the founding fathers and the
formation of this country but what we
ask ourselves now is given our current
situation given perhaps an evolution of
societal values can we remove
these influences from our society can we
rebuild institutions so that they do not
continue to profit off of these
historical prejudices and imbalances of
power that we still see today and
perhaps one idea for this is to use
science right perhaps an idea is we can
use science and maybe we can use data
science to extract ourselves from the
societal ills and by using data and
science we can fix the problem now I
don't know if anybody here went to
Stanford or knows folks at Stanford or
professor at Stanford Stanford is pretty
well regarded within our field of
computer science and has helped evolve
quite a lot of interesting ideas but
Stanford's first chancellor is here his
name is David Starr Jordan and he was a
eugenicist and eugenics in case you're
unfamiliar was potentially one of the
most harmful classes and racist
movements within the past century
well you Genesis believe and they used
science they use science and very heavy
air quotes here they used science to
prove that poverty was based on genetics
and that somehow poverty was inherited
that people were born unfit they were
born unfit to survive in society and how
we were gonna fix poverty was we were
going to make sure that those people
didn't reproduce we were going to let
those people die out and this allowed
many forced sterilizations and these
forced sterilizations often happen to
poor women immigrant women and women of
color they're vastly over-represented in
the groups of forced sterilizations and
this was all in the name of science
right
this was this Progressive Era let's use
science to fix humanity and social
problems and artifacts of the Genesis
movement even after it fell out of favor
and people started to criticize it
artifacts still exist in our culture
today so how many people here have taken
an IQ test or the SAT test or a
personality test that tests your
aptitude for a particular job or career
these all have base and were first
published by the eugenicist movement and
there are ways that we can measure
intelligence measure fit and hidden
within these questions is often racial
class and cultural biases that we
continue to use in a scientific way so
maybe we can do better than the you
Genesis right maybe we can get it right
this time
maybe we can use data and the ability
for us to collect quite a lot of data to
this time document police brutality
right or police mistreatment of
individuals and I was walking around st.
Louis yesterday I don't know if you saw
these around but they were quite
prominent to me they're on quite a lot
of the stands and maybe this might help
right because if we have body cameras
and these videos maybe this might allow
us to expose unequal treatment of
individuals and the optimist in me wants
to believe that this could be the case
but the pessimist in me worries a little
bit about how this data will be used the
skeptic and me worries that maybe this
data will not be used to help prove
unequal treatment but instead prove
cases where the treatment was seen as
just and instead to choose and
cherry-pick cases where it seems
justified and suddenly you lose data or
lose analysis at a greater perspective
and so another possibility is we know
humans can be prejudiced we know humans
can be biased so one way that we could
potentially fix prejudice or bias is by
allowing computers allowing algorithms
or something like this to do the work
because algorithms are neutral right we
know we can write neutral algorithms and
that they can learn from data and that
perhaps this will fix the problem
because by default the algorithm is
perhaps not going to treat a particular
group different than another so maybe
this is the solution right predictive
policing predictive sentencing and so
forth but the problem arises in the fact
that machine learning and algorithms by
definition we ask them to discriminate
we ask them to discriminate we say we
would like you to make a recommendation
or we would like you to make a
classification of this particular
individual versus this other and so
forth we ask them to form decision
boundaries we want them to make these
choices and then when we feed in
historic data that reflects our own
societal and justices and our own human
prejudices then all the sudden we become
very surprised when they act even more
racist or sexist than any human would
openly do so so we asked them to
discriminate and then we feed them
discriminatory data and then we're
surprised and I don't really think we
should be surprised right and I think
quite a lot of people of course aren't
surprised and this is the problem that
we deal with today and there was a paper
that was presented at the fairness
accountability and transparency in
machine learning conference this past
year that mathematically proved the
feedback loop that occurs within
predictive policing environments as you
can imagine an algorithm that we use to
make a decision about whether a person
will commit a crime or whether a
community or an area of town there will
be crime there we feed in this
historical data which has an
over-representation
a particular group of people or groups
of people or particular neighborhoods
the algorithm adequately says ok you
should go to those neighborhoods and
then you go to the neighborhoods and
maybe you find crime and what this
feedback loop does is eventually a
hundred percent of the police officers
are deployed in one or two neighborhoods
now what is the statistical likelihood
of them arresting someone in a different
neighborhood
if 95 to 100 percent of them are
deployed only in one route so we have
created essentially our own feedback
loop and we have created essentially an
algorithm that is just as president if
not more so than a human would be openly
and so as follows privacy in our society
today operates as a form of privilege
because of my skin color because of my
education my class and so forth I can
use privacy I can turn it on and off at
will privacy is a privilege that I
experience every day but if the
situation were different I may or may
not have access to this privacy I may
not be able to control what data there
is about me so it give us an example how
many people here have used a loyalty
program airline rewards and so forth
right how many people have used this in
the context of buying groceries that you
enter your phone number so you can just
discounts on groceries
how many people geotagged themselves on
Instagram with all their friends and so
forth
I'm starting to see some head shaking
some people yes some people know or sign
in for free Wi-Fi where you have to just
simply say your nationality or email or
your address things like this now
depending on your knowledge and your we
might say paranoia of privacy and
security you may or may not choose to
operate these in in different ways so
you may have a level of security or
technology literacy that is helping you
make choices about what to engage with
here and what not to engage with but all
of us have choices
we're all making these choices were
opting in to share this private
information and I don't want people to
raise their hands but I'm going to guess
that very few people in this room have
had to go through the process of
applying for food stamps when you apply
for food stamps here's just an example
from the state of Missouri these are all
the different documents that they ask
you to produce before you can even begin
the application for food stamps and then
once you get the food stamps quite a lot
of states have implemented electronic
cards for food stamps and so they're
going to track every single transaction
that you make so you're already at a
disadvantage you already need assistance
and then you are forced to give up your
privacy to obtain that assistance there
is no other way for you so privacy in
our society today acts as a privilege
and where there is privilege there is
usually power and privacy operates very
much as a power in our society so when
you think of a business negotiation when
you think we're going to do a business
transaction what we want is we want to
be on a somewhat level playing field
right I want to know about as much
information as you know so that when we
get into the bargaining we kind of can
go back and forth but the problem arises
when we have what is called in economics
information asymmetry an information
asymmetry in economics is the ability
for one party to manipulate the sale or
the transaction in some way shape or
form because they hold more information
and information is powerful right and so
when we think about this in an online
privacy context do we know how much
information the online retailer knows
about us when we go to perform a
transaction do we know if they know how
much we're willing to pay for it do we
know if they know
that we've been looking for this for
some time do they know our location
do they know our salary history our
political affiliations and so forth and
the problem here is that there is an
inherent information asymmetry in quite
a lot of the way that we do online
advertising and quite a lot of the way
that we do online sales in general and
the consumer knows very little about
what the producer knows about them and
this leads to a situation where they
cannot really negotiate the transaction
and the more that let's say the vendor
or the company knows about the person
the less chance the person has to insert
new information as perhaps a bargaining
chip right so if I don't if you don't
need any extra information from me you
already know everything that you need to
determine the price or determine my
eligibility and so forth
then I don't have any power so come back
to you and say oh actually this and
there's very few online transactions or
online interactions where we can insert
extra knowledge that we have or an extra
condition that we have and so forth and
so this imbalance of power operates when
we think about privacy online and so
privacy is privileged privacy is power
and privacy is also security and what I
mean by privacy is security is two part
to answer the first is privacy is
information security it's literally do I
control and do I have determination over
the security of my personal data and as
follows if my privacy is often violated
or if my private information is
available in many different ways to many
different vendors for different prices
or availability then I do not control
the security of that information I
depend on some company the government
and so forth I depend on them to protect
my privacy but I don't have control over
that and with security its
often not if it's when and the problem
that we have with security is now we
have more and more public data sets and
the ability to link these and to create
a more full profile of an individual
becomes easier the larger data sets we
have and the more Big Data solutions
that we have to help us with these
linkings and the second part of privacy
as security is societal security now
societal security and political security
we might argue is our ability to trust
our society it's our ability to trust
one another and the institutions that we
use on a regular basis and when we take
a look at something like Cambridge
analytical we can see an erosion of our
societal trust this is similar with fake
news and other phenomena like this
I share my private information with the
company like Facebook I assume that
they're going to keep my privacy in mind
whether or not you can argue that
Facebook API was operating as designed
or that it was a privacy breach is
neither here nor there because it
happened right in Cambridge analytic Oh
was able to build these political
profiles and use them to influence
people now one could argue maybe those
people would have done whatever they did
anyways but that extra nudge may have
helped and the fact that now there is a
constant debate of over what we can
trust when we see online and what we can
trust when we work with companies like
Facebook this erodes our societal
definition of security
and so with privacy and fairness if
privacy has all these attributes it's a
form of privilege it's a form of power
and security then as follows
privacy is unequally distributed privacy
is not equally distributed amongst
people within the US society and maybe
even within society as a whole
and this becomes a problem because quite
a lot of people that do automation
machine learning these types of things
with other people's data quite a lot of
us actually benefit from eroding our own
privacy so I'm willing to give away my
data because it usually works out for me
Siri is helpful it's convenient
instacart means that it knows what I
want to order and it delivers it right
to my door these are things where I
benefit from giving companies more data
about me and it creates nice things in
my life I want to do this but that's not
the case for everyone and because
privacy is unequally distributed and
because some people don't get to opt in
to sharing data this creates an unequal
treatment and in Virginia Eubanks book
automating inequality she went and
studied several different automation
infrastructure within services for
people that don't have a choice about
their privacy in these situations she
looked at a welfare system in Indiana
that was automating things she looked at
section 8 housing in Los Angeles and
getting homeless folks off the street
there and she looked at child services
in Allegheny Pennsylvania and what she
was able to show through a series of
very eloquent stories journalism and
also statistical research is that for
poor folks in the United States
privacy means inequality and automation
and control of more of their private
data usually means further inequality
for them and therefore this unequal
distribution of privacy within our
society means that we have unequal
treatment and unequal experiences of
data collection so this leads us to what
we could possibly do about this
situation right I'm so called data
scientist I do machine learning I would
like to use data to help society rather
than hurt it and so how in knowing all
of these things that I know about
privacy how can I do this in a
thoughtful and appropriate way now
Cynthia Dwarf should hopefully need no
introduction but I will give a brief one
just in case she's a researcher and I
would say an activist within the field
of data privacy and data security and
she is the creator of differential
privacy which you may have heard about
as a measurement to measure privacy loss
within a database system or other
queryable system this was a new more
strict definition than previous
definitions of privacy loss that we had
used and he's really fantastic and can
hold us perhaps to a slightly higher
standard when we think of private data
collection and after her paper on
differential privacy in 2011 she
released another paper that explored
continued to explore privacy called
fairness through awareness and the
concept behind fairness through
awareness is we should treat similar
people
similarly meaning that all things equal
between you and I myself as woman
identified and you as man identified all
other things equal that we should be
treated the same way by let's say a
classifier and what she was able to
theorize in math math
proof is that there exists a mapping
space an intermediary space where we can
create a fair metric or fair
representation of a person and that this
similarity that we see within the input
space we're the only thing different
between us is perhaps a private
attribute like my gender identity if
everything else is similar then we
should be able to hold that same
distance within a classification space
that that should not be the sole reason
why I am treated differently than you
should not be this private attribute or
these series of private attributes
depending on if you're thinking of
multi-dimensional space and so in
fairness through awareness she was able
to prove that indeed this space exists
and further research on the topic began
to dive a little bit deeper in how this
intermediary space or this mapping can
be used within the field of machine
learning and so a later paper made by
the University of Toronto or several
researchers at the University of Toronto
along with Cynthia dork was called
learning fair representations and in
this work they actually implemented her
idea of this fair mapping and what they
were able to show is here let's take the
graph on the Left they have the UCI
adult data set this is a data set that's
used in machine learning often to talk
about ethical or fair machine learning
because it has all of this data about
individuals including their age their
race and their gender and the target
attribute or what we're trying to learn
is whether they make more or less than
50 thousand a year and so as you can
imagine this displays some let's just
say societal prejudices towards
different races and gender and age and
what we have here in the yellow ish on
the far left of each of these accuracy
and discrimination is the logistic
regression so this is
the baseline this is let's not try to be
fair let's not try to retain privacy and
let's just learn what we can learn and
what we have on the far right or the
dark blue for each of these charts is
the learned Fair representations and we
can see in both of these examples that
the accuracy is quite high so we retain
a lot of utility in the data but that
the discrimination is quite low and
these the only difference between these
charts is the optimization that they use
so either minimize the discrimination or
maximize the Delta between accuracy and
discrimination so we want as high
accuracy as possible and it's low
discrimination as possible the other
bars that we can see these are other
ways that we think about ethical machine
learning is a fair Bayesian approach as
well as a regular regularize logistic
regression you might be thinking okay
how does this work this sounds great
right accuracy high accuracy low
discrimination sounds great how does it
work well it works by optimizing three
things the first thing that it attempts
to optimize for when finding these fair
representations is that the mapping from
X to Z space satisfies statistical
parity and what this means is the
mapping is fair now statistical parody
was used within the paper but we can use
other definitions of fairness we can use
other definitions of algorithmic
fairness if we want to and our venerian
on is a fantastic researcher who is
released recently 21 different
definitions of algorithmic fairness so
we can choose depending on our task how
we want to define this feminist but the
first requirement is that it Maps this
statistical parody which means fair
treatment for groups the second thing
that it asks is that the mapping to z
space which is this fair representation
space retains information in X outside
of the private attribute or the private
variable and what this means is we
retain as much information as possible
without retaining information about this
privacy aspect so we want to retain
information but we don't want to learn
whatever we want to keep private and
this is of course difficult to do not
impossible but difficult and the third
thing that we have is that the induced
mapping from X to Y and I'll skip the
parentheses is close to F and this
essentially is quite a long way of
saying that we retain some level of
accuracy that we can find an accurate
representation of the output space so
that we can do machine learning right
because if we destroy all information
and if we destroy all target information
that we can't do machine learning and
for those of you within the machine
learning space maybe you're already
familiar with this paper but if not
you're thinking this these are
contradictory these are contradictory
optimizations and you're right
so depending on the task these can
optimizations can play against one
another and in order to find a solution
we have to tune it and we have to decide
what is most important for the task and
sometimes this is going to be very
difficult because sometimes this is
going to mean that we find out that the
only indicator of whatever target we're
trying to learn the only indicator of
making over $50,000 a year is that you
are white and a man and if we find that
out this is going to be very difficult
for us to figure out a way to do this
that is both fair and respects the
privacy of the individuals within these
groups another way to solve this same
problem is to treat it as an adversarial
learning problem this was actually a
paper that was released earlier this
year which i think is really fantastic
and this adversarial relationship to
learn these theorem biddings is
something that we can do but I first saw
it at go data-driven which is data
science
does he based in Amsterdam with in
adversarial learning operation what we
have is two machine learning models one
that's trying to do one thing and
another that's helping with the error of
the first one and in this case we have
the same adult data set and the first
classifier is trying to classify is this
person in above fifty thousand a year or
below and the second machine learning
model is trying to guess or predict the
private attribute based on whether the
person is supposed to earn above or
below fifty thousand a year so it's
essentially trying to erode the privacy
of that group it's trying to say okay
less than fifty thousand it's probably a
woman
and this lost the more accurate that the
second discriminator model is this
counts has lost towards the first
algorithm so the first algorithm has
these competing optimizations between
fairness and privacy and accuracy and
after one hundred and fifty iterations
of the deep learning frameworks after
one hundred and fifty epochs we see that
we meet the requirement for disparate
impact which is a legal requirement
within the United States as far as
employment goes and so back to our
initial question which is can we do data
science in a way that allows us to
expose societal ills while perhaps not
inserting issues of privacy right
because we don't want to violate
people's privacy but we'd like to
potentially use data science to help us
fix social problems well one way that we
might be able to do this is to collect
data in a private manner and if I can
guarantee your individual privacy but
prove that there's unfair unequal
treatment for a larger group then this
creates a space where you can safely
share information with me and we can
perhaps fight societal injustice --is
together
because as is happening in the US
Congress today what usually happens
today when we want to fight unfair
treatment is some individual has to give
up more of their privacy some individual
has to go forward or a larger group of
individuals have to go forward and they
have to erode their own privacy and
potentially face even more unequal
treatment and perhaps there's a better
way right if we smart software engineers
and machine learning engineers in the
room and so forth perhaps we can find a
better way and I put this slide up as an
example this is from the New York Times
but it was data collected on a google
internal spreadsheet whose aim was to
expose the gender pay gap at Google and
there are some women that are using this
data along with their own personal
experiences to file a class-action
lawsuit against Google based on the pay
structure that we can both see here from
the spreadsheet that people opted in to
share their data for and also the
individual experiences and perhaps if we
have better data collection like this
that insures individual privacy
perhaps we could eventually even have
class-action lawsuits that do not have
to Road the privacy of the individuals
cited within that lawsuit particularly
not in a public way which leads me to
privacy by design we cannot collect data
and use data in a private way unless we
implement our products in a way that
ensures privacy by design privacy by
design is founded on several seven
foundational principles by Ann Kovu Kovu
Qian I believe and she published this
years ago and said here are the
different things that we can implement
as software engineers he's a she's a
computer scientist as software engineers
to ensure privacy by design because if
we can make privacy the default in the
products that we build
and the data collection that we do and
the services and the systems that use
this data can be warfare and we can
perhaps ensure more fair and
representative treatment of individuals
not based on a private attribute while
still being able to explore in just or
unequal treatment of a larger group and
that is exactly what I'm currently
working on at Kay I protect is how can
we make privacy by default easy how can
we make it so you do not necessarily
need to be a privacy expert to implement
proper privacy in your data processing
at this moment in time and how can we
educate not only the people that are
working with the data but the end
consumer the user so that they can
determine the level of privacy loss that
they're comfortable with because privacy
is not an honor off it's an entire scale
and so this is something I'm incredibly
passionate about and hopeful that we can
solve because what I believe is that
privacy is a fundamental right and when
the GDP are the general data protection
regulation was first being written and
then passed the eu-parliament more than
two years ago it started a conversation
saying would this be a game changer
would this mean that large corporations
would rework their architectures to
ensure privacy by design privacy by
design is actually one of the
fundamental principles of gdpr and there
was a lot of debate and hope maybe this
is going to change things
you know maybe privacy rights were gonna
be for everyone but we see how GPR
hasn't been implemented thus far right
gdpr has essentially called created what
I like to call first class and second
class data citizens if you have the luck
to live in Europe then you have some
fundamental data
we can argue whether they're perfect we
can argue whether they're going to be
implemented right we can argue about all
of this but you have a legal precedent
and right and access and actions for
your data and instead of changing this
for everyone what this has meant for
other nations is business as usual
and what this has meant for other
nations is just more of the same and it
was a little bit terrifying for me on
May 26th when I was surfing across the
internet and I saw how many of course I
have also VPN so I can't see all the US
sites still but I saw how many of the
u.s. sites turned off access and I had
this moment which was similar to the day
I woke up and I saw the news about
Ferguson because I had this moment where
I felt like I was looking in the mirror
and I said what have we become what have
we done where some basic privacy
principles in our data processing where
rather than implement those we did like
to turn off access for an entire
continent this for me was a disturbing
day but I'm still optimistic and I'm
still hopeful and here we have Lady
Justice she was a Greek goddess and then
a Roman goddess and she's shown in quite
a lot of the court houses within the
United States and many other nations
across the world and she's shown often
with her scales which show her equality
her fair treatment she represents law
and fairness and order she's sometimes
shown with the sword so that she can
defend justice and she's often also
shown when the blindfold and the
blindfold represents the fact that she
does not
mistreat individuals based on something
that she sees in them she's not going to
mistreat or choose a different sentence
for you based on their skin color she's
not going to ask for your gender before
she determines that you can get health
insurance the idea is that she is blind
to these private things about you and my
challenge for us is that as machine
learning engineers and practitioners as
software engineers and practitioners we
can use our intelligence we can use our
ingenuity we can use all of the
knowledge that we have to figure out a
way to implement something more like
Lady Justice to implement something
where you can have control and rights
over your data and you can have privacy
and you can have truly implemented
privacy which is I would argue our final
stand for fair algorithms thank you very
much
[Applause]